[Musique]
oui mais il ya d'autres moyens de se
protéger que la vaccination genre quoi
là on est en train de parler d'une
méthode qui a permis de mettre fin aux
pires épidémies de l'histoire et d'en
éviter d'autres et au delà des épidémies
on parle d'une méthode qui garantit de
ne pas choper des maladies atroce et
mortelle genre le tétanos pour citer que
celles là et en face en propose quoi
alors maria en fait en tout cas rien
qu'à prouver que ça marchait remettre en
question le seul truc là
scientifiquement prouvé son efficacité
pour le remplacer par des méthodes comme
ça au feeling ce serait prendre un
risque énorme hommes voire des maladies
ou des épidémies réapparaître alors il y
en a qui disent qu'on peut laisser faire
notre système immunitaire de façon
naturelle
mais si ça marchait il y aurait pas eu
toutes ces maladies toutes ces épidémies
ces handicaps lourds etc ces mêmes
justement pour ça que les vaccins ont
été créés parce que ça suffit pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]